In an entertainment industry that is packed
full of superhero crossovers and tie-ins – where
bigger team-ups and shared universe stories
are becoming the norm – it’s becoming
increasingly important that superhero films
do more than increase the amount of CGI mayhem
on screen.
Long before they were all the rage in Hollywood,
superhero stories were allegorical reflections
of our world at pivotal points in time.
They might be fun and colorful but many comics
are also layered with powerful messages of
inspiration - tales of everyday people overcoming
the odds.
Comics teach us that some battles aren’t
won by the strongest or most powerful heroes;
sometimes, everyday heroes can win – even
when they lose.
But what if the hero that wins by losing is
also one of comic book history’s favorite
crime-fighters – who happens to be facing
off against an equally beloved Justice League
hero?
For years fans have debated whether Batman
can beat Superman – but today, in our latest
docu series video, we suggest that not only
can Batman beat Superman, the Caped Crusader
can still win even if he loses.
Batman Meets Superman
It be surprising to hear that, despite near-instantaneous
popularity back in the 1940s, it took several
years for Batman and Superman to appear in
a comic book story together.
The pair graced the cover of World’s Best
Comics #1, joined by Robin, but the Batman
and Superman adventures inside those printed
pages remained entirely separate.
Strangely, the first time the heroes actually
shared a storyline, it was on the radio – not
in a comic book – when the Dark Knight made
a guest appearance on The Adventures of Superman
program – marking the first of several guest
spots from the Caped Crusader.
Nevertheless, it took another seven years
for the heroes to appear in a comic book cross-over
– in a campy 1952 story that saw the future
Justice League leaders, or more specifically
their alter egos Clark Kent and Bruce Wayne,
sharing a cabin on a cruise ship (where, of
course, hilarity and trouble ensues).
Several more years followed, and in 1954,
World’s Finest Comics officially became
a Superman and Batman book series – in which
the pair fought villains together.
World’s Finest Comics was an important moment
in DC Comics – as well as the cascade of
team-ups that would follow in the coming decades
but it also marked the foundation of a key
dynamic in Batman and Superman’s relationship:
Batman was the brains, even though, on his
own, the Caped Crusader was still a capable
fighter - and Superman was the brawn, even
though, on his own, the Man of Steel still
possessed a keen mind.
It was a necessary distinction – previously,
the heroes had existed in entirely separate
worlds, where Superman took-on super-powered
threats and Batman solved crime as The World’s
Greatest Detective but – bringing the heroes
into the same world, meant that comic book
writers needed to ensure that Batman was still
just as fun to follow as his god-like partner
in crime-fighting.
Over the years, as Superman writers gave the
Man of Steel new abilities and greater feats
of strength, and Batman writers armed the
Caped Crusader with slick gadgets and high-powered
vehicles, the dynamic between the heroes was
taken to its logical conclusion: where Superman
battled with raw physicality and super-human
powers, Batman contributed with tactical savvy
and specialized implementation of custom-built
weaponry.
However, even as the friends grew closer – and
inspired an entire “league” of justice-seeking
heroes to join their cause, DC writers began
to explore ideological differences between
the two iconic heroes.
An Ideological Conflict
Where Superman wears a symbol on his chest
that stands for hope and endeavors to inspire
and protect all mankind, Batman is the product
of a city overrun with corruption – where
only vigilante justice could wrong the rights
of a failed system.
For Batman, Superman’s optimistic outlook
wasn’t a strength, it was a sign of naivety
- and a dangerous liability in the hands of
an extra-terrestrial with god-like powers.
Specifically, would happen when Kal-El was
driven mad or became frustrated with humanity
– and sought to protect the world through
dictatorial acts of intimidation and aggression?
It’s the kind of worst-case scenario that
only an obsessive and pessimistic vigilante
like Batman could see coming – but, given
his outlook and the people in his life that
had been corrupted, it’s understandable
the Caped Crusader would be tempted to take
precautions - in order to protect humanity
from any potential threat (foe or good friend,
alike).
Driven by these ideological differences, with
Batman fearing that Superman could become
an unchecked threat to life on earth and Superman
believing that Batman’s brand of vigilante
crime-fighting is a threat to true justice,
Kal-El and Bruce Wayne have (on several occasions)
forgone friendly debate in favor of a full-on
fist fight.
On the surface, a god-like superhuman with
the Man of Steel's powers should make quick
work of a billionaire in a cape and cowl;
yet, Bruce Wayne is more than your typical
costumed vigilante – he’s a costumed vigilante
and genius inventor with access to kryptonite.
Batman V Superman
The Dark Knight has used a myriad of strategies
to subdue Superman – including controlling
Kal-El by (an admittedly hollow) threat to
the lives of innocent civilians (exploiting
the kryptonian’s need to protect innocent
life) – but two of the Caped Crusader’s
counter-Superman measures rise to the top:
power armor and kryptonite-infused weaponry.
Despite its armored bulk and shock absorption,
the armored Batsuit is deceivingly nimble
- enabling Batman to put up a respectable
fight.
An integrated hydraulic exoframe enhances
Wayne's movements and attacks - while also
protecting him from the full-force of Superman's
abilities.
In the power armor, Batman can deliver ground-shaking
punches and kicks, capable of sending the
Man of Steel reeling, while also providing
enough flexibility for the Dark Knight to
dive, dodge, and counterattack.
Conversely, when Batman couldn’t overpower
Superman with power armor, he’s also tried
weakening the Man of Steel.
While the Dark Knight has infused dust from
Superman's home planet into everything from
smoke bombs to liquid capsules, on two separate
occasions Batman outright forged kryptonite
weapons in service of punching the Man of
Steel into submission.
Kryptonite gauntlets were introduced in the
divisive follow-up to Frank Miller's Dark
Knight Returns, The Dark Knight Strikes Again
but, given that Batman can't always predict
when he might need to fight-off Superman (and
it isn't practical or fashionable to bring
kryptonite gauntlets everywhere), the Dark
Knight is also revealed to carry a kryptonite
ring in the center pocket of his utility belt.
Still, even with the use of power armor and
kryptonite, Batman has never been able to
outright defeat Superman physically – only
subdue him.
Which brings us to the real reason that Batman
would ever fight Superman: to remind that
world that even god-like kryptonians can bleed.
Do You Bleed?
the Caped Crusader is often depicted as wary
of the Man of Steel - and has, in the past,
created myriad contingency plans For that
reason, it's no surprise Ben Affleck's Dark
Knight in Batman V Superman seems suspicious,
looking to actively knock "Metropolis' Savior"
off his high horse.
Batman might not be able to kill a fully-powered
Superman but armor and kryptonite weapons
have given the Dark Knight enough of an edge
to succeed in his primary goal: reminding
Kal-El (and the rest of the world) that, should
the Man of Steel ever overstep the line between
do-gooder and despot, heroes will rise to
stop him.
Achieving victory isn't always the same as
winning.
After all, Superman defeated General Zod in
Man of Steel but it’s still hard to call
the outcome a win for the Big Blue Boyscout
– given the death toll, collateral damage,
not to mention Kal-El’s neck-snapping end
to Zod).
Even though he is beloved by millions, many
DC characters (whether human, superhuman,
or supervillain) still consider Superman a
potential danger to Earth – but feel powerless
to hold the kryptonian accountable.
To that end, what if Batman doesn't need to
beat Superman to a bloody pulp, but only needs
to show that Superman can bleed, that he's
not invincible, to beat him?
Fans will have seen a similar idea played
out in countless other stories, including
Zack Snyder's breakout film 300 (where a group
of Spartans gave their lives to make Xerxes
bleed - and prove he is not a god), as well
as Miller's "Dark Knight Returns" - where
Batman doesn't necessarily expect to kill
Superman, he just wants to push back against
a fascist government that wields Superman
like a blunt instrument.
Taking a stand to gain an ideological victory
may sound like a purely intellectual distinction,
but it's one that modern comics have explored
in depth - including Marvel’s "Civil War"
event.
To that end, the Dark Knight doesn’t need
to knock Superman out in order to win (and
make his point), he just needs to last long
enough to show the people of Earth that, together,
they are not powerless against Superman - and
that the Man of Steel will be held accountable
if he ever loses sight of his “humanity.”
Simply put, if a single man in an armored
exo-suit can go toe-to-toe with a super-powered
extraterrestrial, Batman’s stand would make
Superman and the people of our world think
twice.
It might sound high-minded (especially in
a conversation about a hunky, spandex-wearing
extra-terrestrial battling it out with a billionaire
vigilante dressed in bat costume) - but a
moral, not physical, victory is usually the
outcome in nearly every time Batman and Superman
have faced-off (at least in the battles where
mind-controlling neuro toxins aren’t a factor).
Given the pair’s history, and mutual respect,
it makes sense that the most important thing
that Batman may ever do, is keep his super-powered
friend grounded – even if he has to take
a beating in order to secure an ideological
victory.
What do you think of our explanation?
Let us know who you think would win in a battle
between Batman and Superman – and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.